[Music]
Chuck I grew up in New York City I know
that and
I thought in my naivete you know when
you're five or six every city has tall
buildings like this I would say to
myself and that's just not the case
right and you know you visit other
cities their tallest building is you
know 20 stories tall or 50. it's they're
more tall buildings today but when I was
growing up I just found tall buildings
fascinating and I would drag my
telescope to the tallest of the tall
buildings and that was my little sort of
uh Hideout from civilization where I
could commune with the cosmos nice but
there's something interesting about tall
buildings is they see farther away than
you do on the ground floor
okay they see farther away okay okay
that's why the Crow's Nest of old
sailing ships right that's why they were
very tall not only to hold the sails but
the net that what they call the Crow's
Nest up there right that person is the
one that was looking for land land hoes
because they say why whoa whoa why are
you being all judgy about the don't
don't do that to the land why are you
judging the land like that nobody that
land is able to do and see anyone it
pleases you up here talking about land
ho that's not cool
so they will be the first to see it
they will be the first to see land and
because they're higher up okay and
so they say you know all North the
starboard bows everybody be looking
waiting for it they will see it later
than that person did right it provided
the ship is headed in that direction
okay that is because
Earth is round okay
it's a simple fact so you've been paid
to tell us
you're on the payroll Neil
they got to you they got to you Neil
this is how that happened all right so
now I'm at the top of a building
the Empire State Building and
on the 86th floor they used to open that
to astronomy groups they might still I
haven't checked in a while because that
was a it's a it's an outdoor outside
the observation deck and the Top of the
Rock of 30 Rock that's an open outdoor
space and so you want it to be open
because you're going to train your
telescope on the universe so you can get
a view so it turns out
because you can see farther away than
other people can
it means
the sun sets last for you than for
anyone else in the building if you're on
the roof that's kind of cool it's kind
of cool that's right so if you go back
into the street to do this experiment
well the sky has to be very transparent
no schmutzy clouds or Haze or pollution
or anything so what you do is you look
at the building
and you're on the ground floor and you
say in this instance the sun has set
then quickly look at the building and
you will see the sunset going up the
building floor by floor
oh
that's so weird basically it's Earth's
Shadow you don't think about it that way
but it's Earth's Shadow rising up the
building as the sun sets opposite from
it and if we do the math
the sun will set you know a 10 foot
space between floor 10 12 feet the sun
will set one floor per second
excellent one before so if you're on a
60 story building it sets a minute later
for you than somewhere on the ground
floor that's pretty cool very cool do
you know the tallest building in the
world
uh it's that thing in Dubai yeah the
Burj Khalifa okay say it Chuck Birds
Khalifa okay this is still not as cool
as Wiz Khalifa who I would rather see
that's not true I like Wiz Khalifa but
I'd rather go to the Burj Khalifa
because no the Burj Khalifa I've never
been it's like half again as tall as the
World Trade Center was I mean it's just
huge yeah totally huge so do you know
what Muslim holiday
begins
at sundown Ramadan Ramadan okay so it so
it begins with the first sighting of the
new moon in the calendar month
appropriate for that in the in the
Islamic calendar it's it's a loony solar
calendar so the moon matters in this but
so it begins when there's Sundown and
only at sundown you have to fast during
the day beginning that time you fast
during the day and you get to eat at
night okay night is defined in this
interpretation of the Quran by when the
sun sets um just below the Horizon right
if you live in the Burj Khalifa
uh you're gonna be hungry for a little
longer a little longer a little longer
so get down to the ground floor with
your snacks bro
everybody's in the lobby outside
everybody's chomping down on the food
so so the people at the top floor they
have to wait another basically two and a
half three minutes before the sun sets
for them to stay according to code wow
for what this is that's right now it
turns out that particular Passage
is interpreted differently between two
different camps within Islam so one of
them is the exact moment the sun sets
below the Horizon and the other one
talks about just sort of when it gets
dark sort of after Twilight and so
there's a difference in interpreting
when I read the passage it kind of felt
like the end of Twilight to me rather
than this exact moment because in that
exact moment it's still very light out
it doesn't all of a sudden get dark see
for me I'ma read The Passage would I
take it with four o'clock Fork
you hungry Chuck four o'clock four
o'clock okay
then you wouldn't be a devout Muslim
that's all this is true so it's a it's a
case where the sunset matters now how
about in Judaism okay the beginning of
the next day is the sunset or the
previous day okay and so the the Seder
and other celebrations for the following
Day begin at sunset on the previous day
that's right okay yeah
so what happens if you're in the Arctic
at the time of year where the sun does
not set oh you're atheist
that's it I know I no longer I no longer
believe in God
well at the time the Bible and and the
Quran were written that the Arctic was
not yet discovered right and the and
Earth was still basically flat and so
the idea that you'd have these the these
these
um 24 hours of sunlight 24 hours of
Darkness are not manifest in the Holy
books and so there was no provision for
it that's all so I spoke with some
Jewish people and they were telling me
uh that what they do is they they follow
the the tradition of whatever their home
city is or they just go go back to
Jerusalem and do it for so so they link
up with the city we kind of do that when
we go to the moon what time is it is uh
is it on the moon right it's Houston
time it's Houston right yeah yeah but
they are talking to Houston so you know
or they were okay
talking to God I mean they can do that
that happens that's been known to happen
that's a good one you got me on that one
okay okay well when next time you talk
to him be like yo man how come you told
me sun down
you're just trying to trying to starve
me you trying to starve me God is that
what you do
that's a that's a movie plot like Chuck
comes to terms with his religion you
know in the Arctic in the Arctic Chuck
dropped off by accident in the Arctic
right he's trying to do his religious
rituals exactly I can't
sets on buildings for that reason yeah
that's a really cool little I've I
really want to try this now just from a
um like go to the Empire State Building
have one person at the top one person at
the bottom and both taking pictures of
the sunset and and see how much longer
it is for yours for your Sunset yeah oh
by the way there's some will set at
different rates depending on what your
latitude is on Earth but in New York in
New York City 40 degrees north and it
would be true 40 degrees south as well
um and well sorry and it depends on the
time of year but basically it's it's a
it's a four per second I mean I did the
math floor per second so we're we're
good on that what I like to do I like to
take us out
if I may okay I want to read to you a
few paragraphs I wrote reflecting
on
uh on September 11th if I may okay okay
go for it you can actually find this
online it's called sunset on the World
Trade Center okay you just search for
that you'll find it all right Rising a
quarter mile into the sky
the World Trade Center's Twin Towers
were five blocks tall
I live four blocks from where they stood
I saw them Ablaze I saw them fall all
from my dining room window which within
10 seconds of each Tower's collapse
offered less than one inch of visibility
while the opaque dust cloud of
pulverized concrete rolled by
from that same window Blue Sky now
appears where the Twin Towers used to be
the World Trade Center was a veritable
vertical Universe I think about it often
I think about the people who worked in
the towers the tourists who visited the
observation deck the diners at windows
on the world I think of all those who
lost their lives
when I look hard for a peaceful way to
remember the towers I cannot help but
think of them as observatories
on the top floor you could type
greetings into a computer that would
transmit your message into space by the
North Towers radio antenna for all
eavesdropping terrestrials to decode
the towers were so tall that for someone
on the Observation Deck The Horizon was
45 miles away
the distance was far enough along
Earth's curved surface for the sun to
set two minutes later for the person on
the observation deck than it did for
someone on the ground floor
if you could have run up the stairs
one flight per second you would
literally have stopped the sunset
alas you would have eventually run out
of breath or run out of floors in either
case
at that moment you'd lose the Sun for
the night as it set gently below your
horizon
New York City's Twin Towers have lost
the Sun forever
but I take comfort in knowing that the
sun will rise again each day as it has
done a trillion times before
wow very poignant I have no jokes for
that man I don't
it's just that I just gotta I gotta let
that be that's uh let's just all keep
looking up
[Music]